اعربه الولايات المتحده عن قلقها من
اقتحام وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
اعتمار بن جفير باحات المسجد الاقصى وما
صاحبه من خطاب وصفته بالتحريضي
والاستفزازي واعربت الخارجيه الامريكيه عن
انزعاجها الشديد من سماح حكومه نتنياهو
للاسرائيليين بالاقامه الدائمه في مستوطنه
حومش غير القانونيه معتبره ان مثل تلك
التصرفات تعيق حل الدولتين
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما حيثيات ومغزى
الموقف الامريكي من اقتحام للمسجد الاقصى
وتاكيد واشنطن على عدم جواز استخدام
المواقع المقدسه لاغراض سياسيه هل يحمل
هذا الموقف رسائل امريكيه جديده لحكومه
نتنياهو ام هو مجرد تكرار لمواقف سابقه في
حالات مشابهه كيف يمكن ترجمه هذا الموقف
على ارض الواقع لكبح جماح حكومه اليمين
المتطرف في اسرائيل والحيلوله دون المس
بالمقدسات وايقاف سياسه الاغتيالات
والاقتحامات وبناء المستوطنات في الضفه
الغربيه هل يمكن ان تمارس واشنطن ضغوطا
حقيقيه على اسرائيل
ما ردود الافعال الاسرائيليه حيل الموقف
الامريكي وفي اي سياق نقراها مع استمرار
قوات الاحتلال باقتحام المدن والمخيمات
وقتل واعتقال الفلسطينيين كما جرى اليوم
في جنين وكيف ينظر الفلسطينيون والعرب الى
عموم المواقف الامريكيه من المشهد الراهن
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله وهل يمكن
البناء عليها واستثمارها
[موسيقى]
اقتحام هو الثاني منذ تشكيل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الحاليه اثار حفيظه الجميع
تقريبا بمن فيهم المعارضه الاسرائيليه
التي قال زعيمها يائرلابيد ان وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي اعتمار بن كبير يقوم
بخطوات استفزازيه بدل ان يعمل على تهدئه
الاوضاع كيف اذا بالاداره الامريكيه التي
صدر عنها رد فعل اثار السؤال عما اذا كان
يؤشر الى تحول ما في موقفها من سياسات
حكومه نتنياهو اليمنيه المتطرفه اما ان
الامر لا يعدو ان يكون مواقف كلاميه لا
غير المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه ماثيو ميلر استعمل نبره عاليه
في بيانه بشان عمليه اقتحام باحات الاقصى
وتعزيز العمل الاسطواني مذكرا بان موقف
اداره بايدن هو انه لا يجوز استخدام
المواقع المقدسه لاغراض سياسيه وان واشنطن
تدعو جميع الاطراف الى احترام قدسيه تلك
المواقع
واضاف ميلر قائلا نعيد التاكيد على الموقف
الامريكي الراسخ بدعم الوضع الراهن
التاريخي في الاماكن المقدسه بالقدس
[موسيقى]
اناقش الموضوع مع ضيوفنا ينضم الينا اولا
من القدس السيد الون افيتار المستشار
السابق للشؤون العربيه في وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه سيد الون هذا الاقتحام الثاني
لتمار بن جفير منذ تشكيل الحكومه هل في
ممارساته
سياسه حكومه نتنياهو ونهج الحكومه فيما
يتعلق بالاماكن المقدسه
سؤال مهم جدا في هذول الايام
وبدي احكيلك شويه مفاجاه
ما في عندي اي خلاف معكم هذا كل حال
بالنسبه لهذا الموضوع انا بفكر بشكل شخصي
وبشكل فني انه ما في اي حاجه او لزوم من
ناحيه
حكومه اسرائيليه وحسبتا من ناحيه رئيس
الحكومه
لدخول الوزير
هذا الموس الوقت ومش مناسب وفي لسه دايما
في التواتر ونسبه في المناطرك وكمان حس في
منطقه البلد القديم وفي كمان تحسسيات ما
اخوان في المملكه الاردنيه
ومصر والى اخره بشكل عام ااذيني ما في اي
حاجه او لزوم جوهره بالنسبه لهذه الدخول
دخول دخول
من ناحيه اسرائيليه احسن شيء اذا هذا
الاجراءات هذه العمليه من ناحيه ما ما
كانت بالفعل
اذني كمان في خلينا نقول ولازم نكون
بصراحه في
حويه من ناحيه دينيه
احد
كمان نعتمد على ظروف بس في حوالي لكل واحد
اذا بده يطلع على شريف لهذه المنطقه
مقدسه المسلمين
من ناحيته هو
دعايه شخصيه
بدو يستفيد من ناحيه سياسيه
قبال الجمهور اللي
يعتب
وبايني كمان هذه السبب الرئيسي طيب فهمنا
اهداف
بنكفير احسن شيء
فهمنا منك اهداف بتقدير كيف تتعامل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه مع هذه النبره
المرتفعه من الاداره الامريكيه بانتقاد
اولا
اقتحام بن كثير للمسجد الاقصى وثانيا
للاستيطان
لازم نقول مساحه نوضح الموضوع الموضوع مش
اقتحام مسجد الاقصى
ما دخل المسجد باحات المسجد
خارج المسجد بس لكل حال المهم هو انه ما
في اي لزوم او حاجه او كمان نينيه من
ناحيه اسرائيليه
لتواته وكمان زرير اقبال البيت الابيض
من هذه الموضوع بس اظن لازم ناخذ بعين
الاعتبار انه كمان
التصريحاته والعينات من ناحيه البيت لازم
ناخذها بشكل محدود يعني هذا مش تسعيد
سياسي بين الجانبين بين حكومه بايدن وبين
حكومه وهذا مش تسعيد هذا خلينا نقول نوع
من او جزء من التواتر للسياسه هذه اول مره
سيد السيد
افيتار هذه اول مره تستخدم الاداره
الامريكيه عبارات من سبيل بانها استفزازيه
وتحريضيه بان ممارسات بين جفير استفزازيه
وتحريضيه كيف تفهم هذا بتقديرك الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
اديني حكومه بايدن وحكومه امريكا عندها
خلينا نقول
علاقات
محدودها وكمان علاقات
خلينا نقول
العلاقات بين امريكا وبين اسرائيل خلال
اللسان الاخيره ما كانت بشكل
مؤدب او بشكل مناسب
رئيس الحكومه رئيس
بده يزور كمان امريكا من زمان مش من اليوم
هذا يجوز من هذا الجوز من التواتر السياسي
بين الجانبين بس لازم ناخد عند ناخذ هاي
الاعلانات كمان
علاقه محدوده عشان لازم نذكر انه العلاقات
الامنيه كمان والسياسيه العامه بين امريكا
وبين اسرائيل هما على كارت طيبه جدا
ما بتعتمد على
ما في اي تاثير من زي من عمليه او زيارته
دائما الجانب الفلسطيني المتضرر من هذا
الموضوع شكرا لك السيد الون افيتار
المستشار السابق للشؤون العربيه في وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه ونتابع في نقاش موضوع
هذه الحلقه
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه ومن رام الله
الدكتور علي الجرباوي استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت مرحبا بكما
السفير كراولي ما الرسائل التي قد يحملها
الموقف الامريكي الاخير من اقتحامات
المسجد الاقصى
الدبلوماسي كانت هذه تصريحات باللهجه
قاسيه وحاده وانتقادا لاذعا للحكومه
الاسرائيليه بصوره عامه
الولايات المتحده لا تستخدم عاده مصطلحات
مثل غير شرعي استفزازي
على سبيل الصدفه
اعتقد ان الهدف من هذا التصريح هو ان يعكس
تنامي الاستياء في الاداره الامريكيه
تجاهها رئيس وزراء نتنياهو الذي كان قد
تعهد
على انه سوف يعمل على احتواء بينجافير
ومنعه من القيام بهذا النوع من التصرفات
وانا على يقين بانه خلف الكواليس هناك
متابعات حديثه لمحاوله معرفه ما اذا كان
بنجافيل يتصرف لوحده من تلقاء نفسه
لاي مدى هو يطبق السياسات التي اعتمدتها
او ربما منعتها حكومه نتنياهو دكتور علي
اذا السفير كراولي يقول بانها لهجه حاده
من الاداره الامريكيه لم تستخدمها
دبلوماسيا في السابق انتم هل ترون جديدا
في هذه المواقف الامريكيه حيال اقتحامات
وسياسه نتنياهو الاستيطانيه
يعني الحكومه الامريكيه الاداره الامريكيه
مشتاقه هذا هو الشيء الجديد
الذي كان يعني في طوال السنه الماضيه
والحكومه الامريكيه مستاءه ولكن اين يصرف
هذا الاستياء يعني بالنسبه لفلسطينيين هذا
لا يفيد الحكومه الاسرائيليه بكاملها عقدت
اجتماع رسمي الها تحت المسجد الاقصى بمجرد
قبل كم يوم يعني لذلك هذه سياسه هذه
الحكومه انا اؤكد لك بانه بين كثير راح
يبقى مستمرا في اقتحاماته لانه يعرف
ونتنياهو يعرف ان انه اذا ما غضب وخرج من
هذا الاتلاف ستسقط الحكومه لذلك يعني هو
سياخذ الى المدى الاقصى ما يستطيع من
تقسيم الوضع يعني مع الجانب الفلسطيني
اقتحامات
وايضا استيطان كثيف ومحاوله
لضم المستوطنات رسميا للقانون الاسرائيلي
لذلك هذه هي سياسه هذه الحكومه بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده
نحن نريد افعال وليس فقط اقوال الاقوال
اهلا وسهلا يعني ماشي الحال ولكن يعني
ماذا بعد ذلك انا ايضا اؤكد لك بان
الاداره الامريكيه لن تكون باكثر مما
استمرار الاعراب عن الاستياء وقد يكون من
تحت الطاوله محاوله لاخبار نتنياهو بان
يكبح جماح من لا يستطيع ان يكبح جماحهم
لذلك الوضع سيبقى على ما هو عليه والتعويل
على تغير في موقف الاداره الامريكيه تغير
جوهري نوعي غير موجود اذا السفير كراولي
استمعت الى ما قاله الدكتور علي الجانب
الفلسطيني وهو المتضرر الاكبر من هذه
الممارسات لا يرى نفعا من هذه المواقف
طالما انها لا ترتبط بافعال على الارض
واذا كان بن جزير يتصرف منفردا ام بتنسيق
ما حكومه نتنياهو ما الذي يغيره هذا
بالنسبه للاداره الامريكيه لكي تتخذ
بالفعل موقفا يضع حد لهذا الاستفزاز
الاسرائيلي تجاه الفلسطينيين
وانه اذا كانت المنطقه تتطلع الى الولايات
المتحده لحل المشكله سوف يخيب ظنها هي
ليست ما سال جيوسيه بالنسبه للعلاقات
الاسرائيليه الامريكيه المساله تتمحور حول
السياسه الاسرائيليه لنكون واضحين وانا
اوافق التحليل القائل
سوف لن يسيطر ولن يحتوي بينجافير بالنظر
الى خطر انهيار الائتلاف الحكومي
الاسرائيلي نتني يوم في نهايه المطاف وان
جنسيا اذا نهار تحالفه على الارجح سيدخل
السجن وهذا يظهر محدوديه قدره ثلاثي
المتحده على تغيير حسابات نتانياه لاسيما
ان المجازفات كبيره بالنسبه لنتانيا هو في
نهايه المطاف سيفعل ما علي ان يقوم به
وليس ما قد ترغب واشنطن به دكتور علي طبعا
مع تطور الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه لباحات
المسجد الاقصى
عقد الحكومه المصغره اجتماعها الاسبوعي
اسفل
حائط البراق كما كما اسلفت الاغتيالات
الميدانيه الاعتقالات مع كل هذا هل تعتقد
بان الموقف الامريكي ممكن ان يتطور ليكون
اكثر
تشددا فعليا على الارض وليس فقط في الكلام
يعني اولا نحن نواجه هجمه
حاده من ناحيه نوعيتها من قبل هذه الحكومه
والاطراف المتطرفه فيها والتي تتحكم بهذا
الائتلاف يحاولون ان ينهو الموضوع حسم
الموضوع بالنسبه لهم وحسب الموضوع يتاتى
من الضم يعني هم يريدون ضم ما يمكن ضموا
من ارض
الارض المحتله في الضفه الغربيه مناطق سية
ومناطق الاستيطان يعني معظم الضفه الغربيه
يريدون ضمها وترك الفلسطينيين يعيشون في
معازل منفصله عن بعضها البعض الان هذه
الهجمه نراها كل يوم بما يجري في كل مدن
ومخيمات وقرى الضفه نراها في المسجد
الاقصى نراها في حده الاستيطان ولكن هل
بامكان الولايات المتحده او هل تريد ترى
بالولايات المتحده ان تقوم باي فعل مضاد
انا لا اعتقد ذلك الاداره الامريكيه
الادارات الامريكيه طوال فتره طويله دائما
تحاول اداره هذا الصراع ولا تحاول ان تحل
هذا الصراع لذلك اداره هذا الصراع كلما
تازم الوضع قليلا نرى ان هذه ان الاداره
الامريكيه ترسل مبعوثين وتقوم بخطوات
لتهدئه الوضع ليعود الامر الى ما عليه
هذا وضع لا يوجد فيه طرف طرفان طرف نحن في
طرف محتل وفي طرف تحت الاحتلال وما في
امكانيه للمقاربه ما بين موقف الطرفين
يعني لذلك هل بامكان الاداره الامريكيه ان
تاخذ موقفا حاسما من مساله الاحتلال
واستمرار هذا الاحتلال انا باعتقادي ان
الجواب لا يعني وجواب لا كبيره ايضا
السفير كراولي هل تستطيع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان تاخذ موقفا حازما وبالتالي
كيف تتعامل الاداره الامريكيه مع هذا
يعني
الاستهتار
الاسرائيلي في المطالب والمواقف الامريكيه
دائما الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تطالب
اسرائيل
بشيء
والحكومه تتنياهو تقوم بعكسه تماما
ان التصريح الذي صدر عن وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه هو فعلا موقف حاسم نتحدث عن
مصطلحات دبلوماسيه ذات لهجه ونبره حاده في
الوقت نفسه يجب ان نعترف بالواقع جو بايدن
وبنيامين نتانيا هو يعرفان بعضهما حق
المعرفه لكنهما ليس صديقين مقربين
العلاقات الاسرائيليه الامريكيه قويه ولكن
في الوقت الحالي فان العلاقات بين نتنياهو
بايدن تعتبر ضعيفه
وعليه اعتقد ان هناك قيود عمليه لما يمكن
الولايات المتحده ان تقوم به بالنظر الى
الوضع الحالي نحن مرغمون على اداره الوضع
ومنع استفحال الموضوع لسنا في موقف يسمح
لنا بان نحاول حل الوضع
وحل موضوعي الاحتلال بطريقه او باخرى وذلك
لاسباب متعدده بما فيه عناد اسرائيل وكذلك
عناد الفلسطينيين اخر مره اجرينا فيها
حديثا بين رئيس وزراء الاسرائيلي ورئيسا
فلسطيني كان ربما في
2008 نحن نتعامل مع هذا الوضع القائم منذ
15 عاما دكتور علي وسط هذا التصعيد
الاسرائيلي المستمر والانتقادات الامريكيه
برز تطور وهو التصعيد الاسرائيلي وان كان
لفظيا حتى الان على الاقل تجاه ايران وحزب
الله كيف تقرا هذا وفي اي سياق تضعه فيما
يتعلق بما يحصل من تصعيد اسرائيلي في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه
يعني دائما تحاول
اسرائيل ان تضع نفسها في موضع
المعتدى عليه وان تقلق نفسها وتقلق
سكانها من مخاطر والان دائما يعني في
الفتره الاخيره كان كانت ايران هي مصدر
هذا
الخطر الذي تروج له اسرائيل ضدها من اجل
ان تبقي على الوضع الداخلي الاسرائيلي
اسرائيل يعني منقسمه على ذاتها خصوصا
بالنسبه لما يحاول تحاول هذه الحكومه ان
تقوم به مما يسمى بالاصلاحات القضائيه
لذلك هناك شرخ اجتماعي سياسي داخلي في
اسرائيل على هذه النقطه
وايضا هناك
انتقادات
لاسرائيل على ما تقوم به ضد الفلسطينيين
لذلك تحاول دائما ان تظهر بان هناك مخاطر
خارجيه وان تصعد لهجه يعني التوترات ما
بينها وبين طرف من الاطراف لكي تحافظ هذه
الحكومه كما الحكومات السابقه في اسرائيل
على امكانيه ان يبقى الوضع الداخلي لها
موحدا وان تصد الانتقادات يعني القادمه
عليها من الخارج لذلك هي محاوله
لتحيد او لتحويل الاهتمام من ما تقوم به
ضد الفلسطينيين وتقوم به داخليا في
اصلاحاتها القضائيه الى مساله خارجيه
تماما وهي
هذه المره وفي يعني خلال السنوات القليله
للماضيه كان الموضوع المفضل لاسرائيل هو
ايران
كراولي كيف ترى توقيت تصعيد اسرائيل من
لهجتها تجاه ايران وحزب الله على لسان
استخباراتها
اعتقد
السياسيه في واشنطن لتالاما كنا قلقين من
تنامي تاثير الايراني في المنطقه حول هذه
القضيه
على المستوى نفسه
من الشرق فعلا
ان يكون هناك تاثير كبير على المستوى
المنطقه برمتها اذا نعم
فيما نرى ايران تعزز من دعمها مع الوقت
لحماس
فهذا يزيد هذا الوضع الصعب صعوبه وتعقيدا
ولكنه في نهايه المطاف لا يحل محل الحاجه
الى جلوس
فلسطينيين الى طاوله واحده وجها لوجه من
اجل ايجاد حل نهائي وهذا ما افتقدناه في
السنوات الاخيره مفاوضات ذات معنا وذات
تاثير بين الاطراف التي هي معنيه بحل
الوضع شكرا لكم يا سفير كراولي في واشنطن
والدكتور علي الجرباوي في رام الله
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا متابعه الى اللقاء بامان
الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]